if you never met a man before what about
your father I had no mother I was
brought to life by you oh that's neat
you
see youtubers is Charlie so we got some
new footage we learned a little bit
about the villain of the movie Ares even
though we haven't seen him at least as
we know in the footage so far there is a
new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video
previous winners are announced at the
end be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything
so we got new footage the actors are
talking about the film there really like
five big takeaways and it's all about
Wonder Woman's origin story and how that
feeds into her ongoing conflict with her
main villain Ares so number 5 her origin
story is kind of a mess when you go like
way back in the comics it's kind of the
same problem you have with a lot of
comic-book characters that's why you
know they're having rebirth right now
they're sort of reimagining the
characters reading all that continuity
together in a really understandable
simple way in the original version of
Wonder Woman's origin story she was
created from a lump of clay by Hippolyta
her mother and then given life by the
goddess Athena so each of the Greek gods
bestowed upon her their powers so she
was like this amalgam creation like a
golem that was created by them but then
later incarnations made her the daughter
of Zeus so it seems like what the movie
has done has sort of combined those two
things in a really simple way where she
says she has no father she was created
by Zeus so she's not like the other
Amazons even though she is an Amazon
that's why they're all badasses so you
could consider them metahumans but
technically they're not metahumans this
is where you get into a lot of Greek and
Roman mythology trying to weave that in
with traditional DC Comics metahumans
people with powers but she is like a
step above the other Amazon so number 4
learning the truth of things so in
almost every version of her origin story
she runs into Steve Trevor who is sort
of like the entry into the real world
for her where she learns what's really
going on like she's been isolated on
this island in the context of the movie
the Amazons have sort of bailed on
humanity but she's only been around for
part of their history there's this whole
implied history that goes
way back further beyond that that
explains why the Amazons bailed on
humanity in how they rebelled against
Zeus why he's not around in why Ares is
such a villain so number three Ares has
typically been her main villain he's the
god of war he tries to create chaos
he hates humanity wants them to die so
tries to find creative ways to make that
happen
during the new 52 comics he even became
her advisor sort of trying to co-opt her
so like I said trying to learn the truth
of things Wonder Woman
wants to learn the truth about what
really happened what's really going on
with Ares in why the Amazons have the
wrong idea and should not have bailed on
humanity
the thing about Ares though is that in
the context of the DC extended universe
it's set in the real world the Man of
Steel movie was meant to be an example
of what would happen if an alien with
the powers of a god came to earth how
would people react to that in the
context of the Wonder Woman movie they
had to find a really practical way to
weave in all this Greek mythology so
what would a god look like in the DC
extended universe he would probably just
look like a normal person most of the
time but even in the comics Ares can
change form he can appear as an old man
he can appear as a young man he can also
show up in full battle armor and change
size just become this big hulking brute
somebody that looks like they could take
on a Wonder Woman instead of just a
normal person but for the most part the
way they're presenting the Wonder Woman
movie is that he's mostly acting behind
the scenes pulling strings trying to
orchestrate chaos in the downfall of
humanity through World War one in this
weird gas that they're playing with so
doctor poison seems like somebody who
might be working with Ares we don't know
if he's actually Danny Huston in
disguise
Danny Huston is just like a great
character for playing villain so if
we've actually already seen Ares in the
trailers before and just not realize
that he would be the leading candidate
but they haven't confirmed anything in
number two you know back story of how
Ares came to power
he's a very power
for God but Zeus is more powerful you'd
have to get rid of Odin before Loki
could take over in the Thor movies so
how do you get rid of Zeus so in the
context of what the actors have been
saying in this version of event the
Amazons and Ares revolted against Zeus
and killed him so Zeus is either dead or
God basically sidelined not present in
the movie you know technically you can't
really kill a God so there was actually
a comic book during the new 52 that
tried to address that problem but
however they handle it in the movie Zeus
is not around and Ares is left to run
amok the reason for the revolt is that
Ares was jealous of man because Zeus
favors them more which sounds very in
keeping with Greek tragedy so that led
to a revolt in the ancient history of
the Amazon so a big part of the movie is
Wonder Woman trying to learn the truth
of things taking the side of man over
the Amazon and going against Ares
because she's of these people so the
Amazons had this way of life they've
taught her to believe certain things but
then Steve Trevor comes he says you've
never met a man so there's just like so
many things that she's questioning in
the movie so she tries to find her own
truth and stop the world from blowing
itself apart which sets her against Ares
but number one what does it say about
her fight with Ares going forward in
movies because Superman fought Zod in
the first Man of Steel movie he killed
him at the end so that was a really big
deal very controversial but Zod is
technically one of Superman's biggest
villains like Brainiac is another one of
Superman's biggest villains Superman
just has a lot more villains in his
rogues gallery there have been fewer
Wonder Woman comics so fewer Wonder
Woman villains of that caliber that you
would consider really good picks for a
movie so what they might do in future
movies is just allow Ares to slink away
so that he can continue to trouble her
if they do more Wonder Woman sequels
they're probably going to wait till the
Wonder Woman movie comes out to decide
what the future of that character in
spin-off movies is going to be are they
going to do Wonder Woman too is she just
going to be a Justice League character
think about what they did with the
Captain America character somebody that
was pulled out
time like Wonder Woman is an ancient
character reflecting on how she got to
this point you know most of the movie
takes place in the past but then they
jump forward to the Justice League
period just like Captain America took
place during World War two then he was
thrust into modern day in the continuity
of the New Avengers film so that's
probably what they would do with Wonder
Woman sequels they would all be set in
present-day with present-day villains so
even in present-day
the gods are still very much a problem
for Humanity so there's plenty of people
that they could pull for Wonder Woman to
fight but I think it just depends on
where they leave the character at the
end of the Wonder Woman movie at the end
of Justice League the way the producers
have been talking about her is that
she'll actually be fully actualized by
the time we get to Justice League if
you've ever read Superman read son it's
like a what-if story what if his pot had
crashed in the Soviet Union and it just
shows you that he's very prone to
influence of the people that he grows up
with so Wonder Woman is just trying to
break free of the influence of the only
people that she's ever known fed this
dogma so let me know what you guys are
most hype about Wonder Woman versus Ares
do you actually think that we'll see him
in his full Greek armor do you think
that we'll even see him in the movie at
all even if he's acting through other
agents like doctor poison here really
good news too they just confirmed the
Green Lantern Corps movie is coming it's
going to be like lethal weapon in space
so I'll do a Justice League Green
Lantern video soon there's a whole bunch
of other comic book news so let's say
congratulations to this week's flash
ring giveaway winner
revelation please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video I'll
just announce the winners the next time
I post a DC video where you guys wait so
there's a post you can click here for my
top 50 characters that are going to be
in infinity war and you can click here
to learn all about my predictions for
the back half of the flash this season
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight